[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when the runner rebels were dreaming of
the season
starting 0-4 was not the plan but here
they are trying to win their first game
of the season
and win at a big 12 school for the first
time in 14 years
today was a banner day for perseverance
and not panic
unlv traveling to manhattan kansas
population 54 000 people none of whom
were at the game to see
coach bruce weber have more protective
gear than a surgeon no gear could
protect this bucket though bryce
hamilton exploiting the purple power
cats
for 18 points second half rut and rebels
ignite they lead just by two that would
change the hustle leads to david jenkins
and he
catches fire from three unlv wanted this
game more as seen by the hustle on the
offensive glass another board for unlv
the caleb grill
the pride of wichita kansas and his home
cooking
now prepare yourself for the launch on
the fast break caleb grill
emphasizing the word man in manhattan
the kansas state high jump champion
clears the bar of
disbelief meanwhile jenkins has a jumper
and he's not afraid to use it 25 points
68-58
unlv wins at a big 12 school for the
first time since beating bobby knight
and texas tech 14 years ago
the rebels are in the win column but i
do think our guys had a really
stubborn intentional desperate mindset
and that's something we're going to
continue to demand as we move forward
and you work harder and you work harder
and you outwill the situation and
that's what we're going to have to do as
a team because we don't have that margin
for air so
um look there's not going to be anybody
more desperate for the running rebels to
win a basketball game than their head
coach we have guys with great character
who came together and we stayed positive
towards each other and we knew
it wasn't going poor forever and we knew
we're going to get one win and we're
going to try to build on this move
forward